il était arrivé libre ce matin au palais
de justice
le docteur fait chier on est ressorti
libre toujours il n'ira pas en détention
les juges de la chambre de l'instruction
donc reconduit son contrôle judiciaire
pour les victimes présumées
le coup est rude quand quelqu'un est
soupçonné de 24 emplois zone mans le
fait qu'il reste le livre comprend pas
on comprend pas tout simplement
comprendre chaque fois on est entraîneur
osica y avoir du nouveau épique loi
franchir une marche est là on a toujours
du mal en région ce matin les avocats
des parties civiles semblait sur deux
depuis trois semaines pas un jour sans
qu'une révélation n'apparaisse sur le
docteur peschier son profil
psychologique ces manquements au
contrôle judiciaire
et cette liberté de manoeuvre alors
qu'il est le suspect numéro un
il est difficile de comprendre que parce
que le docteur pelechian une une assise
financière importante
ils soient toujours sous contrôle
judiciaire pour moi pour moi il ya eu
violation du contrôle judiciaire
je le dirai je lirai l'autre au palais
de justice les heures passent les
victimes s'offre le temps d'un pique
nique dans la salle de la cour d'appel
un bras de fer à huis clos s'est engagé
autour de l'anesthésiste ici en chemise
blanche ses avocats repousse point par
point
l'impensable
s'il est placé en détention provisoire
vous déséquilibre est complètement eux
la possibilité pour lui de se défendre
et pour ces constats il faut savoir
qu'actuellement il ya ya près de dix
sept tomes on peut pas imaginer aller
aller en détention avec les 17 hommes
pour préparer pour préparer un dossier
les juges confirment la liberté pour
l'anesthésiste une décision courageuse
pour ses avocats la décision résiste à
une rumeur un peu folle et non maîtrisée
et elne elle tient compte du fait que ce
dossier extrêmement complexe mérite des
investigations
l'ong la voix de la défense n'est pas
une voie subsidiaire ce n'est pas
toujours le procureur de la république
et à la vérité il peut se tromper
la police judiciaire peut se tromper et
c'est ce que nous disons dans cette
affaire depuis deux ans et demi les
avocats des victimes dénoncent eux un
traitement de faveur
on a quand même réalisé un exercice
assez surprenant sur le plan procédural
pour pas allé jusqu'à la détention on
arrive à mettre un double contrôle
judiciaire c'est quelque chose qu'on a
du mal à comprendre au niveau des
participants
le docteur peschier ne s'est pas exprimé
cet après midi il est tout de suite
reparti près de poitiers dans sa région
d'origine